and we are back for the final round
action here at the second annual Karen's
Cup the action is heating at the eyes
but we have a very special guest
detective Tracy Hawke with is with
Alejandra to talk about do the right
thing Thank You Jan great to have you
here on the show you are from a program
do the right thing tell us a little bit
about it do the right thing is an effort
between several police departments the
st. Louis City Police Department the st.
Louis County Police Department the
southern Illinois police chiefs
Association as well as the st. Louis
area police chiefs and together we
recognize kids who have done something
positive yet something tiny like they
turn to penny in from the playground do
they save someone's life every single
kid who is nominated is a winner in our
books and we recognize them for that nah
man this is a local initiative for a
said moreover nationwide there are
several chapters throughout the United
States we recognize kids who are in the
greater st. Louis area so think like you
know anything that would be considered
part of great state greater st. Louis
yes those would be Cordy Bryant in them
that we recognize that one of our tops
on ceremonies and so any kid who is in
that say Louis area that a a family
member a teacher an administrator a
community member they have recognized
them for doing something positive we
like to recognize them at our top ten
ceremonies as well as they're recognized
at the school level that's awesome what
does it take to be nominated or to win
an award here and do the right thing
what does it mean a lot of them it's
it's a wonderful boost for
self-confidence and and it's a way to
for any kid who who does something small
all it takes is a few moments for that
teacher that administrators to get on
the Internet go to our website hit the
nominate button and put in something
about that kid and then we have judges
who go through every single story every
month everything every single story and
we have a huge you know debate as to
which one are going to be our top ten
winners and once we get through all of
them we pick ten stories that are
recognized at that ceremony that we were
seeing there and the police chiefs come
out we have them at three different
locations so we recognize those kids who
have done something amazing who might
have been the friend of that person that
that they know
needed right at that moment it's it's
great because it doesn't take much to do
that nomination a few minutes of your
time and like it really touches the
hearts of not just that kid but their
parents oh my goodness there's like
beaming at the ceremony they're so proud
of them they can't get over how amazing
it is I imagine some of the stories what
has touched your heart are student of
the year for last year his name is Tony
we get the nomination actually from the
prosecutor's office from st. Louis
County we we read it and it was just
amazing
so Tony was nominated because him and
his mother were living together Tony was
about 15 or 16 at the time and his mom
was in an abusive relationship the the
gentleman that she was involved with
decided to stab her multiple times that
day Tony tried to step in and protect
mom for me hurt further the guy tried to
stab him
Tony ended up hitting him a couple of
times large gentleman like an adult male
that he was fighting was finally able to
kind of stun him enough that he could
get out of the house and go to the
neighbors to get help they called the
police the police came were able to
arrest the gentleman but the prosecutors
were so impressed with not only his acts
of trying to keep his mom safe but also
making sure that in court when they were
going through the whole process
he was the support there for his mom he
testified even when it was hard and it
was emotional and it was terrified he
went in he he testified and the jury was
touched the prosecutors were touched the
investigators in their office were
touched all of us I do the right thing
were touched as well we had people even
after their main ceremony who had to
stay after just in order to tell him how
amazingly proud they were of him and we
were so proud that's why he got to be
our student of the year for last school
year that is an amazing story there must
be so much strength from him in such a
difficult time he really blew us all
away it was amazing I can't imagine but
well I see that you had stuff a lot of
nominations and not all of them are you
know such convoluted stories with
terrible from the beginning you guys
have other smaller stories that also
they lock there and do the right thing
of course we have stories where the case
turn in that penny of the playground or
he was nice and helped the teacher with
doing something each of those kids they
get a certificate a t-shirt a pencil and
it's mailed to the school's a lot of our
schools have great big ceremonies where
they recognize the kids for doing those
things and we had you know at their
monthly character education program or
at their morning meetings they recognize
those kids they're getting those
t-shirts to proudly wear around the
school well that sounds great tell us if
you see a community member doing the
right thing how do I nominate them
you're gonna go to WWE
you're gonna click on that nominate
button fill out information about
yourself because if they're one of our
top ten winners we would make sure that
you can come to our ceremony to add a
little bit of information about the kid
and where they go to school so that we
can reach out to the school and the
parents and we can make sure that that
packet gets to them either at their
school or when they come to our ceremony
well what a great way to recognize the
little good things that happen all
around us all the time I'm sure that
it's great to reward the positives right
in my line of work it's amazing to be
able to reward the positives so
frequently we're stuck with those
negatives it warms my heart it makes my
day and all the other detectives and
supervisors in our in our unit are just
like thrilled to be able to be part of
this well that's absolutely heartwarming
thank you for joining us here in the
program guys you know how to nominate
look out for the positives in your
community that's what brings us all
together thank you again for coming you
know thank you very much for having me I
appreciate that
[Music]
you